let's move on to the college bribery
scandal how sweet is this dr. Dre with
his daughter truly young showing off
what looks like her acceptance packet to
USC I mean it's a great moment for any
parent but then Drake took it one step
too far on social media you know the
same if you live in a glass house brah
don't throw no stones
dr. Dre is now deleted this Instagram
post from this weekend bragging about
his daughter's acceptance into USC my
daughter got accepted into USC all on
her own
no jail time he was seemingly poking
funny parents like Lori Lachlan and
Felicity Huffman but Dre suffered online
backlash because he with a business
partner legally donated 70 million
dollars to USC in 2013 Dre's daughter 18
year old truly young had also posted all
my hard work paid off I'm going to film
school that post is no longer up either
family has a lot of hearts
meanwhile at the Nickelodeon Kids Choice
Awards ironically held at USC on
Saturday the fuller house cast had their
aunt Becky's back where there's a lot of
hard there's a lot of love and a loving
family sticks together no matter what
for accepting the favorite funny TV show
award Candace Cameron Bure let it be
known Laurie had their love they stick
together through the hard times and they
stand by their side no matter how tough
it gets happy College and Laurie's
daughter Olivia Jade also in the middle
of the scandal got some love from fellow
youtube star david dobrik it's the worst
to get involved in anything bad she's a
sweet smart girl so I'm sure she's
holding up good by the way Olivia has
not returned to school and the USC is
investigating you see if other students
may have been involved with the alleged
bogus service yes and while several
college coaches who were charged were in
court today Felicity and Lori are
scheduled to appear in a Boston Court on
April 3rd and you know what we will be
there when they hit the courtroom
[Music]
[Applause]